facile trop facile trop trop facile avec
une gardienne de la trempe de darly
zoqbi de paula fleury n'avait aucune
crainte à avoir face à nîmes
elle a écoeuré les attaquants adverses
et est un an moins d'une mi-temps les
tout derniers rêves nîmois d'accéder à
la finale du championnat casey mais
d'entrée de match pour aller chercher ce
mal c est à 200% réseau mille intensité
succédaient les ricains sont unis
moi ma canne elle fait un match
extraordinaire dame comme si on est sur
des grands matchs par les halles est
toujours présente donc voilà mes
championnats marrakech et je pense qu'on
l'a bien aidé quand même avec la défense
donc voila moi dieu d'inox et la dmrc
ama déposait une défense hargneuse
pendant 30 minutes puis en mode
économique en deuxième mi temps en
raison d'un score très large 21 13 à la
mi temps 30 20 au plus fort de la
domination fleuryssoises le coach local
se permet alors de faire sortir sa
gardienne numéro un sous les
applaudissements du public en roues
libres fleurissent impose 35 à 27 et
attend maintenant son double
affrontement face aux parisiennes d'issy
les moulineaux
on est sûr qu'on va avoir des
difficultés là bas on l'a vu hier avec
le match n ont rien lâché c'est des
bonnes joueuses elles ont appliqué les
consignes al des bonnes tactiques et
voilà on va vraiment essayer de faire un
coup là-bas et avec le public lassé de
faire quelque chose de bien ici
le match aller aura lieu mercredi à
paris le retour le dimanche 31 à orléans
pour l'apothéose d'une grande saison